on a 2013 Toyota Tacoma and it's not a
I'm sorry 15 to combine and it's not
programming in through our Auto Pro pad
so this one's gonna be a manual
programming on board I should say I got
one program to remote Bob here as you
can see and I have this one here it's
not not programmed at all so I'm gonna
try to go I'm gonna go ahead and program
this one in I'm gonna use this key here
step process here we're gonna be in the
ignition
two times it has to be pretty quick
close the door open it twice put the key
in once pull it out close the door twice
put the key in close the door turn to on
turn back to off door cycle press the
lock and unlock at the same time and
then the lock if that cycles one time
that means its success if it cycles
twice it means it's the wrong fob and it
didn't go in so that's pretty much it
guys to program in manually I'm just
going to make sure and then I program
both just in case they get knocked out I
got both of them back in okay guys
thanks